we mounted two very strong campaigns to
get the government to reverse it police
cuts which senior police officers were
telling us would hamper the fight
against terrorism the government you
turned on that that is a good thing and
we also mounted a very strong campaign
for George Osborne to reverse the
unforgivable proposals to cut tax
credits which ultimately hit working
people majority of people living in
poverty in our country are in work they
were the ones who are going to be hit by
this so the reversal in that measure
again is a very welcome thing and that
that's evidence of two successful labor
campaigns that we did as part of a broad
coalition of other groups I mean it's a
labor campaign it was a liberal Democrat
pain it was a Sun campaign it was a date
Davis as I said a coalition of other
groups the tax credit so I mean hardly
points to Jeremy Corbyn is it really on
lawn tax credits well I don't see it
quite in those kind of party political
games terms I think the one thing that I
think has been missing from the analysis
today is what did this budget well
comprehensive spending review and Autumn
Statement do for young people we saw in
the last Parliament and assault on the
opportunities and aspirations of young
people from school to the workplace
education maintenance announced being
abolished trebling a tuition fees the
increase in the minimum wage could do to
come in an April 2016 not happening for
the under 25 we seen a continuation of
that with the spending review today with
a real-terms ten percent cut in funding
for 16 to 19 year olds in sixth form
colleges sixth form and in fe colleges
and also a withdrawal of support for
young people renting in the social
sector so you've seen this assault on
young people in the last Parliament
continuing into this one too and the
other thing we've seen is a increased
tax for apprenticeships on business and
generally an increase under this
government in recent years of the budget
of the burden on business away from the
public safer towards business he used to
be business secretaries is that a good
idea to shift that burden off the
taxpayer into business well I don't have
any objection in principle to business
making a contribution to insert ensure
that we've got a system that is
producing young people with the
technical and vocational skills we
the big skills gap that they need of
course the devil will be in the detail
and of course I mean there are not about
large employers providing the kind of
training we want to see there needs to
be more assistance and help for smaller
employers who find the bureaucracy and
sometimes the costs involved in this
prohibitive but ultimately we shouldn't
get obsessed about numbers because it's
also about the quality of
apprenticeships I mean there's so many
things that are bad and called an
apprenticeship now but 20 years ago we
would never have thought of as an
apprenticeship and what business tells
me is that a third of these three
million apprenticeships that we're
hearing about they want moes to be at a
higher level and that is simply not
happening on the police was that really
a reaction to what happened in Paris I
think look before what happened in Paris
I sit on the Home Affairs Select
Committee we taken evidence from a
number of senior officers including the
most senior in the country Commissioner
Bernard hogan-howe of the met he was
clear what he envisaged been asked to do
before the announcement today was going
to lead to the loss of around 5,000
offers particularly neighborhood police
officers and we know from the
counterterrorism hedmark Rowley and that
they have a vital role in the
counterterrorism effort so this is why I
don't think the chance that I had any
option but to protect the policing
budget and of course the you know the
sense of that was heightened further to
the Paris attacks it finally can we talk
about the figures a bit because I mean
all this is predicated on improved
prospects of the British economy by the
obr the Office of Budget Responsibility
do you believe it means you believe that
the economy is that bit stronger
therefore giving George Osborne that bit
more elbow room what I think in the
short term clearly what the Office of
Budget Responsibility have done is given
him a get-out-of-jail-free card today
because they changed their forecasts on
debt and growth is given him 26 billion
pounds to play with but the problem that
we've got is that they're still
underlying structural problems with our
economy let's not forget a very healthy
economy does not have a base rate due to
Jersey they're right on that 26 billion
the
well they've changed their forecasts
before in fact they've changed them
every single time they produced a full
cast so that 27 billion may not
necessarily be on the table if they
change their forecast when the next
budget is due in March and we've still
got a record trade deficit we've still
got the second worst productivity after
Japan in the g7 and we've still got big
problems in terms of the lack of
investment in infrastructure and that's
not investing enough in R&D and
innovation those new ideas that make us
competitive globally that still is a big
outstanding problem and we haven't seen
it fixed today thank you very much